like true beauty sort of seduces you
toward the good it pulls you deeper into
reality but then there's this in these
more
it because you if you look at how PL was
like you know get rid of those artists
because they because they can make you
think something's beautiful even if it's
not right they're tricksters they can
become propagandists and in scripture
you can see that applied Arts are from
Cain and they bring about the flood so
there's this very dark aspect of what of
what they can bring but then God is
constantly saving that which is
Fallen
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
World hello and welcome to climbing on
Mount Sophia I'm excited today to be
here with Jonathan pajo and David
Shindler again um Jonathan pajo of
course is the leader of the symbolic
World movement which is a YouTube
channel and a website and I think a
printing press now as well right uh yeah
we just started a uh yeah we just
started a press like a few months ago
with our with our fairy tale Series so
yeah yeah so a lot of wonderful things
going on there I mean um so many
resources wonderful people a part of
that um whole movement and then Jonathan
also is a Orthodox icon Carver an artist
and today we'll be referencing some
things from his video on Contemporary
Art I'll put a link here um and then
David Schindler of course writes under
the pen name DC Schindler
um professor of anthropology and
metaphysics I think at John Paul 2
Institute um and then author of many
great works so David and I have been
doing a
series um on David's book Freedom From
Reality
um and so I'll post a link to that here
as well but I was hoping today that we
could talk about art um art in relation
to beauty and how that looks in the
modern world today um and how that's
part of the Diabolical separation from
the world um that we're all experiencing
so I'll throw those out there and any
thoughts that come up
initially well Ken maybe we could start
with the question that right before we
began that you would raise and we hadn't
gotten into and I suspect Jonathan would
have some really interesting things to
say about this but you mentioned that
the distinction between Tech in the in
the ancient sense and modern technology
that you know shares a root but there's
a there's a very different sensibility
implied I mean maybe that would be a
good starting point it's you know it's
not immediately art in the sense of
painting and sculpture but but certainly
related to that um with that seemed like
a good a fruitful yeah I think it's a
great place to start it's like my
actually my intuitions about art part of
my intuitions about art actually came
from Reading haider's questions on
technology and uh and then reading
Ananda kumas Swami's work on art as well
those are the kind of the two sources
that brought me to think differently or
to realize just how differently the
Ancients thought about art and in some
ways the sense that they had the idea of
idea or aist and then Tech was applied
basically it was just the idea of
applying things to the world right so
you you have these principles you have
these patterns and then you apply them
to reality and that
application is is Tech and so that's
actually my that's been my approach to
Art in general and to technology so to
me I don't totally see a difference
between the two it's it's just that and
poesis for for example like even poesis
comes from the word making there's this
idea of like you know you have these you
invoke The Muse and then you make things
with you you actually create things um
and that's been my approach to it and
the reason why I take that approach is
because I think that that's also what's
there in scripture it's it's closer to
the way that the Arts or applied making
is in scripture and it also makes it it
removes it from this weird idea of
expressing yourself or of like creating
Beauty you know art for art sake or
beauty for beauty's sake and all of
these types of of terms that came about
with the
romantics and the later later artist and
rather brings it back to the idea
of you know it's just it's a so anasi
for example says the art remains in the
artist right art is actually a skill art
is not a thing art is a skill that the
artist has to apply knowledge and
principles to the world and to and to
make things that are artifacts that have
a purpose in life and in society and so
technology does that as well uh and the
Arts the ancient Arts that's that's what
they did right the seven the the they
say the seven arts or however you want
to talk about it that's how how they did
it and it's just a different way of
understanding which which also breaks
that weird Duality we have between
between the idea of like pure Tech in
the sense of just gains in efficiency
which is the way that we seem to think
about about technology today it's just
increasing of power basically uh and the
idea of Art in the sense of expression
of something and so to me they're
actually the they're actually ultimately
the same and when we separate them and
we have something like fine art or music
or creative arts and then we have pure
Tech which is just an increase in means
then we have a monstrosity we end up
with we monstrosities on both sides yeah
I want to invite you all to the very
first symbolic World Summit over 3 days
we will finally meet in real time in
real space and everyone from this little
corner of the internet will be there to
explore the theme of reclaiming the
cosmic image of course I will be
speaking but there will also be Martin
Shaw who is an amazing mythographer
father Steven D young of Lord of spirit
Fame there will be Richard Roland from
the universal history series Vesper
Stamper Nas kotar and Neil deg grade
that you've all seen on my channel here
and there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt po Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from February 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon spings Florida visit
the symbolic world.com SLS Summit for
more information and I will see you
there
yeah no that's that's that's great um to
pick up on a couple of things there I'd
like to tease out a little bit more
distinction with technology but I'll
come to that in a moment um this idea of
tech being um an application uh it seems
to me there's there's another dimension
that's that I think is in the spirit of
what you were saying um but it's
formulated a little bit differently and
that is that uh this again would be a
hiigaran sort of sense that Tech itself
is a kind kind of knowing it's it's a
distinctive kind of knowing that that uh
would be different from conceptual
knowing that then gets applied like in a
second moment you have an idea an
inspiration and you take that idea and
then you try to translate it into a
thing through you know paint or or yeah
tone or color that there's there's
another kind it's kind of interesting
and this is I you know I I I'm not an
artist like you are um I I I do enjoy
painting I used one point I thought I
might become but that never never uh
materialized but my experience of of Art
and this seems pretty common um is that
uh you often discover the idea uh as you
as you work with it that it's not it's
not that you first have an idea and then
you apply it but that somehow the very
idea itself comes to expression in a way
that can take the artist himself by a
certain
surprise that that um uh it's still a
manifest it's not just self-expression
I mean some people will interpret that
as just being um you know arbitrary
creativity it's it's it's it's still
truth centered and Truth grounded but
it's a kind of truth that is
Manifest revealed and manifest in the
real thing um that you can then think
about afterwards would would you accept
no well heiger yeah heiger talks about
the notion of gathering right so it's
like the way in which it's an unveiling
is that is that it it gathers elements
together towards and it reveals it ends
up revealing a purpose as you're
Gathering them together so you could you
can understand it as an emergent from an
emergent perspective and from a kind of
top down perspective where from an
emerging
perspective you have all these things
coming together in love and then ex then
manifesting an a hidden reason as they
come together together and then the
other way to understand it is from the
top down perspective which is it's like
it's like a head finding a body or a
husband finding a wife it's like an idea
coming into the world and and joining
itself with a uh with matter and so I
think both of those are are perfectly a
perfectly good ways to explain it yeah
but if you if you think about like
there'll always be so let's say even the
the way you talk about it which is which
is there's this modern it's a more
Modern Way of understanding art which is
this kind of like a you know
improvisational approach which then
reveals a pattern that you hadn't
thought about haven't thought about
right it's almost like it's a form it's
almost like a form of divination it's
like you cast the bones and then you
watch the bones move and then you see oh
oh it's like there's something there
there's some pattern then you start to
draw the lines between the pattern uh
and then you kind of are surprised to
find what what is being revealed so in
that sense that type of art making is is
closer to Divination in that sense but
then you even that you would need to
have the art right so if you if you
can't do it yeah then you're not going
to do anything right you you can kind of
see it but if you can't if you don't
have the skill if you don't have that
art in you then even if you have this
revelation of some pattern that you
hadn't thought about you need the skill
so it's it's still even if you're it's
an emergent uh thing you also need that
top- down control in order to to make it
happen I yeah I that that's I would
absolutely agree with with that that
this idea that you're sort of generating
order simply From Below is incoherent
ultimately it never really works out
there's always going to be a kind of a a
a from above Dimension I I think that's
the modern artist did everything to
attain pure so I don't know if you know
the process it's fun to do like I don't
know if you know the process of a Ki
which was which came about with the with
the um surrealist which was what you
would do is you take a piece of paper
you'd fold it and then we would each
start I would start a drawing and then I
would leave just a little bit of the
drawing left so that you can see but you
can't see what I did and then you would
continue the lines and make something
and then leave a little bit for the
other person and at the end you unfold
it yeah and then you have a a kind of
hybrid monster but then what you're
surprised that you realize that often
there's actually a connection between a
surprising connection that happens
between between the different elements
yeah and that's why I mean that it's
closer to to the way that ancients would
have done divination that's similar yeah
I I'd want to try to steer between that
because I that there's no governing idea
there has to be a governing idea or else
or else you know I I think um I don't
know if you recall the TV series uh from
a few years ago lost that kind of and I
you know I I remember at a certain point
really getting into that um uh uh it was
it was absolutely compelling but at a
certain point the compellingness of it
just disappeared yeah and I think that
was when you know the audience
collectively began to realize that they
didn't know where they were going they
know where they're going they're like
making it up you know um episod by
episode and I mean immediately the drama
disappears it no longer has it's no
longer mysterious or there has to be a
governing idea what what I what I would
want to avoid on the on the flip side is
somehow that you you've got the concept
that the that the artwork is simply a a
physical translation of a concept there
there's it contributes more than that
somehow right there has to be a there
has to be a play between between the two
I always I think like I've been thinking
a lot about
beauty I've think been thinking a lot
about beauty because on the one hand you
know I I remember seeing you know like
that kind of platonic idea right that
beauty is the is the is the expression
uh of the infinite something like that
and I always thought well that's a real
interest that's a good it's a good
description of beauty but then I also I
realized it I had a tendency to describe
Beauty very much top down it's like
beauty is when you see Harmony beaut is
when you see order Beauty but I realized
that actually you know what that's not
true it's not it's not actually what you
perceive as beauty beauty is something
like Harmony joined to a particular m
and so and so it's like it's it's
integrated uh it's integrated Harmony
into a into the contingency of a
particular place a particular thing and
that's when you actually perceive Beauty
so something that is actually too
perfect and too balanced is is monstrous
yeah but you need this weird this weird
like this weird discussion between with
the particular material space um
situation what ever offers and the
pattern which kind of comes down and and
is married to it it's like when the when
the absolute shines through the
particular that you see beauty you could
yeah but the particular plays a part in
it exactly there's no particular the
absolute can't manifest itself and
there's also a way in which the infinite
also
appears mysteriously in in an aspect of
idiosyncrasy that is properly there
right right like the idea of
uh you know this weird idea like if you
read in this in the in the Pro I think
it's in the Proverbs where it says you
know the it says something like the gray
hair like the person's white hair is is
his
glory and it's it's a beautiful image
because on the one hand it's like your
hair turns white so it turns into light
but at the same time it's you dying and
it's like actually your dying is your
glory and so it's like as you settle
into
a kind of particularity that's what kind
of shows your particular Glory yeah so
it's it's an interesting but it but it
obviously can be disconnected from from
the universal but it has to it has to it
has both at the same time yeah you know
Al along these lines there's there's a
uh the the best most compelling
interpretation of beauty that I have
read um is uh from a thinker I think
needs more attention on this matter and
that's fre
Schiller and um you mentioned Play It's
he he he has this definition on on the
surface the definition doesn't sound
like much but when you when he explains
it it really becomes fascinating he he
says that beauty is the appearance of
freedom and what he means by that is is
Jonathan in a way it's a it's another
way of saying the very point that you
made so he said um you know imagine just
a a straight a straight line and a a
curving line
um uh the curving line he says is more
beautiful than the straight line and and
why is that the straight line represents
a kind of an order that imposes itself
sort of irrespective of the
particularity of the matter there it
just mechanically is there and and um uh
in a way allows allows nothing of the of
of the matter to to to appear the curved
line is is the Triumph of order but it's
a Triumph of order precisely in the the
particularity and the constraints of the
matter where the very constraints of the
matter become uh a means of expressing
the the freedom so you get this
incredible um uh marriage use that word
marriage I think is beautiful here of
form and matter the from above the from
below the concept and the the the the
practice the I mean all these things the
yeah universality in the particular some
that's beauty is where it all really
comes together yeah I think so it it I
think that the it's interesting like the
I think one of the most satisfying
images for a human person and that's why
it's so Universal is a is a straight
line with a curvy line around it I think
that that's actually I think we're I
think it's like hardcoded into US yeah
when we see that that line DNA you might
say yeah exactly like when you see that
you see that caducus kind of structure
it's I don't know as I remember being
very young and just drawing that over
and over just because there was some
weird aspect of it that was very very
satisfying yeah and I think that when
you think of those two together like so
Christ on the cross is a good example
where where Christ is usually actually
uh drawn as a as a serpentine figure on
the cross but you have that you have the
straight then you have the curve which
comes and makes and softens it and makes
it a you know and is also a kind of
dying at the same time it's not it's not
it's like there's no going there's no
two ways about it it's like there's a a
kind of letting go right of that of the
of the straight uh but also attached to
it it's like it's weird the cross
obviously is hard to describe because
there's too many things going on in
there but I that my intuition so what
you know I remember a good example
contraposto is a good example right so
if you have a basic simple contraposto
that's not too excessive then you really
get that beauty but if you have someone
standing in front of you that is just
like a pillar right with their two feet
like together and just like obvious it's
not a natural position nobody stands
like that but you would feel ve it would
be very eerie actually to face someone
that way and so the idea is is is to
find the contraposto and if you look at
Christian art there's almost like a good
V there's a visual discussion about
reigning in Roman contraposto but not
eliminating it so if you look at
Byzantine images the the the usual the
Roman Contra Paso for those who don't
know whato is yeah yeah I don't know
Contra Paso is when you is when you have
a figure that stands and then is
unbalanced has their leg out in one way
so that their body curves okay if you
look at a baroque image you'll have
extreme contraposto right like kind of
like that where whereas if in the in the
Roman times it was that's how you would
always show a figure right it would be
like one foot out and one foot straight
and it would make the whole body curve
like an S and if you look at at um
Renaissance the Renaissance would like
recaptured the Roman contraposto there's
something kind of there's something
almost erotic about just the the it
depends how much you exaggerate it yeah
um yeahh and so like imagine a woman
like putting her hip out kind of like
sticking it out right there's something
a bit seductive about it uh and then the
byzantines kept contraposto so if you
look at a Byzantine image you'll see the
figures actually are not standing
straight A lot of people would say oh
the medieval as in icon when you say
Byzantine like a like a Byzantine icon
the figures aren't standing straight in
the the late modern period in like after
World War II some people started
discussing medieval art and started
saying oh medieval art is heretic it's
straight it's everything is brought back
to like a kind of but it's not true if
you look at Medieval images they do have
a contraposto they do they are standing
off but the question is how
much how much is enough how much is too
much yeah and so how do you find that
curve in the body which is not uh
overtly erotic but suggest enough
particularity for it to be incarnate and
human human and beautiful yeah yeah no
that's I mean again that's why what I
like about Schiller's notion is that um
order is not simp L eliminated or
betrayed it's expressed but it's
expressed in this precise this unique
way that that that in fact makes use of
the constraints so that even the
constraints become an expression of free
of the the inner freedom of the and I
that that that sort of thing so so you
know imagine um uh you know you can
think of a garden or you can you can
think of the you know we find certain
movements of animals graceful and other
you know think of a frog leaping through
the air it's I mean there's nothing
graceful about it you know if you watch
it in slow motion it's there's something
ridiculous about it and you see that the
the weight of the thing is overpowering
its own ability you know so it's it's
violently reacting to it by launching
itself in the air but but um uh you know
it's off center and off balance and just
you know as opposed to a you know a
gazelle leaping or something and there
or a bird flying yeah there you see that
that there's a there's a there's the
bird has a weight you know it's light
but it's it has a weight but that very
weight is what gives it the strength to
move itself up and and and there's no
there's nothing in it that doesn't
contribute to so get nothing in it
including its constraints including the
things that that in a way could from
another perspective be oppressive those
very Things become an expression of its
own inner life
andity that's and we just find that
beautiful to see because the thing that
worries me when I see the when I hear
like an expression of or how do you say
an appearance of Freedom yeah the
freedom in appearance freedom in
appearance is in manifestation right is
the I mean I'm sure I'm hoping it I'm
sure he didn't mean that but it's like
because we see
artists that made that move right but
did it in a a kind of uh you could say
uh icon clastic manner right right so
you find I mean to yeah to to qualify he
doesn't mean freedom in the sense of
like arbitrary power to choose right
yeah you're meaning freedom in the sense
of that of Freedom as as a responding to
the call of the good more than than
Freedom as an assertion of oneself
that's right as
an order in the art world what you have
in the 20th century is people who
declare you know without thinking twice
that that Art For Art's Sake yeah and so
what we want is to we want to liberate
ourselves from Arts imprisonment to
particular crafts or to particular uh
ideologies or whatever so I just reread
portrait of the Artist as a Young Man
and you see right the the the narrative
Arc of that is that Joyce has to free
himself from religion free himself from
his family free himself from from his
nation in order to become an artist that
can focus now on beauty as if Beauty
expresses itself outside of these
constraints and outside of these frames
yeah right fly past those Nets he says
yeah no that's that's that's it's a very
different I mean that that's why you
realize these um these questions about
what beauty is in involve I mean a a
fundamental interpretation of the of the
meaning of the world the meaning of
being you know it's not just um a
question of taste
uh yeah the meaning of order and and and
speaking of the meaning of order I I
don't know if you're familiar with
Christopher Alexander if you he he's
he's expresses uh some of these things
really I find um in a really compelling
way that you know this the the the
contrast to art for Arts sake would be
this notion of um the integration of of
life and art this is a principle you
talk about in that that one video but um
but a healthy integration where there's
you know there's nothing that beautiful
that's not useful and nothing useful
that's not
beautiful and uh you know you you you
don't have like mechanistic use on the
one hand and then try to add
superficially onto it completely
meaningless ornamentation to to to sort
of heal the the violence of the of the
you know of the mechanical World exactly
yeah to heal the heal the vience that's
a beautiful way of saying it I think
that that's exactly the that's the the
good diagnostic of what happened in in
the 20th century is that art and it what
it did is it also made everybody
ultimately alienated because the the art
that was born the high art that was born
out of the the modern period became so
abstract and so difficult that it left
everybody behind and so nobody really
ended up caring so I mean let's let's
say it like James Joyce portrait of the
artist of as a young man is actually
really fun to read it's beautifully
written and it's amazing but read
fegan's wake and you just want to pull
your hair out at every page because it's
just it's just
inaccessible to people it's just a comp
I mean it's it's dense and it's and it's
full of of patterns and numerical
symbolism and it's all that but it's
like it's impossible to read you know
and there there's a connection between
this is something I've been thinking
about uh uh recently um the the
marginalization of Art and and even
Philosophy from the the Public Square
you know I mean it used to be the case
that the the thinkers and the artists
were uh figures of authority of a
certain sort and they spoke right at the
in the center of the of the Public
Square and they what they said and what
they made then uh gave ordering to life
there was there was something that that
um communicated itself in terms of the
the public Horizon but now you know we
have this completely abstract sense of
what politics is on the one hand and the
in the public sphere um is again sort of
a mechanical um order that has nothing
to do with human life and then then we
have to in a way Champion these extreme
expressions of life and subjectivity on
the side and then you get this strange
dialectic between the two yeah where
nobody is and and then the the the Arts
that are available to the public Spa
public Square are basically just like
you know like a hit of cocaine like
they're just just basically like just
the pornography yeah it's basically
pornography it's like it's just a beat
you know a beat that you dance to or
like you know a lit up advertisement
that you look at it's like it's like
everything has been reduced to to
immediate pleasure and to mechanistic to
mechanistic uh to to mechan kind of
mechanize cold reality so we don't have
the you know and that's why like that's
why I tell people go to church one of
the reasons obviously I want people to
go to church for their own spiritual
life but for their own salvation but
there's also the idea that the church is
one of the only places left in the world
where you sing for a reason yeah right
where you where you move for a reason
where you could have Beauty for a reason
and that you can be inside and
participate and that we all are in this
dance and it used to be that all Society
had some aspect of that dance to it but
it's broken down so much that there are
few few places except for maybe your
home your family and the church or that
is still accessible to us yeah you know
it makes me think about you brought up
the notion of Seduction before when you
were talking about the Contra Paso and
it seems like like true beauty sort of
seduces you like in in the socratic
sense of Seduction like it seduces you
toward the good s it pulls you deeper
into reality but then there's this like
in these more
just in the Bible but also in kind of
Greek Greek mythology and ancient
thinking it's always a dual it's a dual
thing it's not it's not it's not clean
it's not just simply there's a there's a
there's a healthy suspicion towards it
because you if you look at how Plato was
like you know get rid of those artists
because they because they can make you
think something's beautiful even if it's
not right they they're they're they're
tricksters they're they're they're
propag they can become propag propag
propagandists and in scripture you can
see that the applied Arts are are from
Cain and they bring about the flood so
there's this very dark aspect of what of
what they can bring but then God is
constantly saving that which is Fallen
he's constantly kind of covering the the
elements so man develops technology
develops cities and God's like all right
you know and then he's like okay well
I'll give you a pattern for the
Tabernacle you know and then I'll give
you you then will found Jerusalem and
we'll have so it's like there's this
covering of the of the but it's always
duel even though even if and the the
bronze serpent is a great example
because the bronze serpent in the story
of The Bronze serpent you get the two
right it's like God tells Moses put up
the bronze Serpent and this will this
will become like an image that everybody
can look at and that it'll heal the
it'll heal the nation and then later in
the Bible it's like cut it down burn it
because it's become an idol
yeah the very same object yeah I I I
like how you said um uh Plato's concern
that that um that these artists can make
something that look beautiful that isn't
I think that that formulation is really
crucial because I would want to hold on
to the idea that it's not that beauty is
um morally ambiguous and there's good no
it's art that's more of the ambiguous
but not yeah right right no but that's a
really crucial point because I think
people miss that I mean that that in
fact Beauty itself and I think one of
the reasons that it's as you say it's
not clean it's not sort of obvious is um
I like to say that that Beauty has
something of an Invitational character
it's sort of it's it welcomes and opens
up and invites but that you know that
appeals to freedom on the on the on the
uh recipient side one has to respond
properly to it and and because one has
to respond properly to it there's built
into that the possib possibility of of
betrayal of taking it interpreting it
falsely um taking it as kind of
immediate gratification so I I think um
you know there's no such thing as impure
Beauty in fact I mean Beauty always even
in impure cases there's there's a
glimmer of something that's true that
can in fact lead one out of the impurity
yeah there's a crazy story uh from the
desert fathers of these monks that are
walking down the road uh and then all of
a sudden this this woman young woman you
know like naked on a on a I think she on
a donkey or something like walking
towards them and all the monks are like
just diverting their eyes like don't
look at it and the one this one old monk
is just looking at her like kind of and
then when they go by all the other monks
like why are you looking at her really
she was so beautiful yeah and it was
just like for him he had it's like he
was beyond the desire it was just he was
seeing a beautiful creature of God
because it's always just well for most
of us that's probably best not
that way but it's just like which side
of it you're on almost like can can the
arrows that that because I think of that
in like the problem of the erotic right
this problem of the erotic in a downward
sense right like I'm trying to consume
I'm trying to have I'm trying to take
versus Aros in a higher sense that this
is becoming way for me
yeah yeah I mean that's that's I mean
and uh it's not it's not that OS is
two-faced or something but that that
that AOS in principle is a call to
what's higher but it's a call that that
um can be uh falsely interpreted or
betrayed I mean I think that's but I
mean the the the the interesting thing
and this is you know PL Plato is so
fascinating on this you know the the
good um uh jonan you were talking about
how modern art doesn't speak to
people PE it speaks only to experts you
know and then and then the masses Chris
Alexander is really good on this there's
a kind of the masses then sort of go
along with it because the experts tell
them that this stuff is beautiful even
though them makes them feel sick or or
anxious you know when they at it um that
that uh you know goodness there's the
idea of the good has a certain kind of
inaccessibility and you know kind of a
Perfection that might make it seem a
Transcendence might make it seem Out Of
Reach um but there's there's not there's
no human being on Earth that doesn't
respond to Beauty you know yeah truth we
C can we can we can ignore goodness we
can but everybody responds be there's a
c there's a um uh you know if you think
of um to to use a kind of cryst ogical
image that you know Beauty in a way is
goodness um leaving its Transcendence uh
in order to enter into the very depth of
the of the material the flesh you know
the Incarnation um to the very ends and
uh and and that that uh Place able to
sort of speak and call one back up um
there there's something really um
profound about the the Christian
understanding of that I think I think so
in in the Book of Revelation the image
of the Heavenly Jerusalem is is one of
my favorite ones to kind of understand
the relationship between between tech
and and let's say human civilization and
its relationship to God and so there one
of the descriptions of the Heavenly
Jerusalem it says that all the nations
bring their glories into the City and it
says that all the kings offer their
glory to into into the City and so the
idea is that all these externals right
they they have to be offered up and
that's the way for them not to
become dangerous right it's like like
you said it's like the Aeros if the
Aeros is transparent and Aeros pulls you
through things into the presence of God
then it's then that's the right that's
the right way to to to to deal with it
but the problem of course is that
because it
offers certain pleasure then it can
seduce you to stay at the level of the
appearance or to stay at the level of
the first you know and so I I like the
way that the church fathers that well
the the the the the Herm the the the not
the desert father but like the the the
monks in the filocalia how they talk
about sayic spir hetic fathers like this
the spiritual tradition in terms of
because it's because falia means the
love of of of beauty Bea yeah but then
in the text they're saying they say
weird things like they'll say ignore all
spiritual
experiences right it's like if you have
a vision ignore it if you see a miracle
ignore it ignore everything and you
think like what a weird thing to say
like why are they doing that and and you
think are they
against a be beatific Vision are they
against and you're like well obviously
not because the tradition is full of
them right they're not against it
they're saying it's almost like if you
ignore it if you don't attach yourself
to it you'll actually have more of it
right right and then you'll actually be
you'll be gathered up higher yeah so
it's not so it's like yeah you'll see
Miracles you'll see all that stuff just
don't attend to them too much because
then you lose the purpose of them being
just a a kind of a pull into the higher
States yeah it it's the same as the monk
walking down the road right like if it
it's more obvious to everyone that
there's some sort of Shame associated
with you know you stopping at the level
of the naked woman but if you stop at
the level of hey I had a great vision I
had this great Transcendent experience
it's similar you're still doing the same
thing it's just it's more acceptable
yeah yeah so I I like this principle
though that that doesn't mean then
losing the pleasure of it I mean
paradoxically and ironically it's
deepened um like the the example that
you gave from the church fathers but in
Plato too you know the philosopher I I I
I I wish I had the exact number he says
that the the philosopher in a way uh
compared to the one who's seeking
pleasure ends up actually having
something like 500 29 times the pleasure
the pleasure he does the calculation
yeah precisely precisely because he's he
sees it in relation to its ultimate
source it's origin it's its first
principle yeah I'm always asking people
in in some of my in my talks whether who
has most the most pleasure a millionaire
at a at a banquet or a monk that's
eating bread and has fasted for three
days it's like it's pretty sure that the
monk is having more pleasure than the
millionaire but he's not looking for it
right he's doing he's kind of trying to
avoid it but then it's it's coming to
him like there's no way to avoid it this
this reminds me a little bit of Jesus's
parable of the talents right because
those guys like it's the ones that give
it away that they get more of it it's
like great I got I got a talent or you
know now I've got two talents or
whatever but every time you get it you
give it back
away yeah losing your life is finding it
it's yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's why
the question of Beauty in Christianity
it's like it's a it's a weird and and
sometimes how can I say this like I
think the I'm the Orthodox I think
sometimes get it a little off because
there's something about Christianity and
Beauty which is paradoxical because
there's a sense in which we're we're
meant to see Beauty in the extreme of
its ugliness yeah like we're kind of
asked it's almost like we're asked
to to be willing to go to the end of
what we consider to be pain and
suffering and ugliness and all these
things and to and to and to have and
that there's some Glory there's some
hidden Beauty in that and obviously it's
dangerous because I don't want people to
think this is a kind of masochistic
thing I don't think it is but you know
there is something about about the cross
which is right weird like it's a
terrible thing but then it's also so we
say you know the lifegiving cross we say
that that it's the the that Christ on
the cross is creating the world that
he's the Garden of Eden that he's the
you know that he's a flower like all
these images that were used even in the
middle ages of the rose on the cross or
different types of of images
um and the same thing with martyrdom and
Relics and all of these these things
that happen in Christianity which is
this strange Paradox of of Beauty in the
in the least expected place or beauty in
the in
the so that's that's a that's one to
integrate the uh uh there's a Benedict
the 16th has a an address to the
Ministers of culture it's a it's uh
available online it's just a short
address that he he gave but he he speaks
about that Paradox and the Christian
appropriation of the ancient sense of
beauty and Aros and how it it IR Ires
this paradoxical character precisely in
the cross it really is moving you know I
I don't I don't want to be sort uh seem
obsessed with Plato here but even expect
you to be PL has a has a an anticipation
of this I mean it's it's it's amazing
that he you know he presents Socrates
himself sort notoriously ugly the those
Socrates you know as um uh when he opens
up you know in the Symposium um uh and
you see that the he's like the the uh
the statues that have the statues of
gods inside of statues of gods and and
when when Socrates you open them up you
see these glories that are are are you
know it's
spellbinding so there's there's
something about that um the the Paradox
of a more radically Transcendent and and
glorious Beauty um in the uh in the most
extreme I think I think precisely
because of the you know Augustine says
that that one of the things that
constitutes beauty is is
contrast and I I think we all find
things like Paradox striking for that
reason that that um um uh I'm gonna
actually use that as a way to tie into
an earlier point that we made right in
the beginning of the conversation um you
know un unity and
difference uh that um we might think
that that uh collecting different things
under a unified idea is is the essence
of beauty and that that's and there's
something really true about that but
there's also something about um the
differentiating of unity that's also
beautiful and I think in something like
um uh Paradox and contrast and then you
know the the the ultimate example is the
the the glory of the Lord as hunor from
Bazar would say in the cross yeah there
you have what would seem to be an a
uh an
absolute difference an absolute
difference you know move moving all the
way to nothing suddenly itself reveals
itself to to to be the deepest Unity
there's something about that that's that
becomes unspeakably Beau and it's and
you have to avoid you have to avoid the
SAT Mass I mean right one can reading
it's also because the because like if as
as an artist I think as an artist and
someone who's interested in art it's the
kind of question you have
to ask yourself because so let's say if
you look at Francis Bacon as a painter
let's say he's a good example where you
know his most one of his most known
works is is called
crucifixion and uh it's like a it's like
these broken monsters really is what's
going on in that image and the question
is what is so what's the difference
right so it's the same like for example
I'll give another example I thought like
I thought that mil Gibson's passion was
over the top like I like mil Gibson and
I like his movies but that movie I just
I watched it and I thought that it was
indulging in it was indulgent there you
go it was indulging in violence in a way
that I thought was was not useful but
not for some a lot of people had a
different reaction to it but it's like
and so if I look for I look for example
at like a late like kind of Spanish or
like Mexican crucifixes and you see
Christ you know his his knees are flayed
and you know it's like he's got he's
he's just like his his whole body is
just ripped apart and it's like this is
the crucifix in the church
right it's it's so I I I like what's the
balance how do we find the balance where
we're showing the scandal of the
crucifixion but we're we're also trying
not to indulge our Fascination
for uh
for something that is you know dark
Fascinations let's say for death right
um right and it's the same with music
too right no these are these are
delicate matters and require real
prudence and spiritual discernment um I
mean because there's a drama in this you
you know it's problematic you simply
rule certain things out it's problematic
if you kind of automatically affirm them
there's there's a there's a real um uh
discernment is the best word that that
is essential at every moment yeah yeah
there's also like a shock like there's a
there's a sense of
shock that is dangerous in the realm of
beauty because it's it's it's like it's
the popcorn version of yeah of beauty
because it creates intense experiences
but it usually Fades very quickly and so
you can create you know it's like
watching a horror movie right you can
create intense emotion aesthetic intense
emotions in people but those are not you
know they're not very deep they don't
they don't transform transform you yeah
that's the word
yeah yeah and so it's like I it's
important especially if we're we're in a
world now that we're kind of struggling
I think a lot of the churches are are
struggling to figure out H how to deal
with the question of Beauty and the
question of Music the question of
participation you know I I have weirdly
enough like I I have Protestant pastors
who want to meet with me and talk to me
about how do we find this this balance
between the entertainment kind of flashy
light show rock and roll culture that so
many churches have fallen
into uh and then yeah sorry I don't want
to interrupt go go ahead go ahead well
just just I mean there there you you you
you see that's that's Beauty that's
being used as a a kind of strategy for
for recruitment or
or we're going to we're going to use
this to communicate a message and that's
you know become technology in a way yeah
right there you go we we need to come
back to that technology question at some
point yeah it be it's it's sort of a
technological use as opposed I would say
as opposed to something that that would
be like a genuine Tech um that would be
an interesting way into that that like
so would you mean by by
technological use is something like
pure pure utility like yeah I would I
for for me it's where you separate means
from ends and you you kind of perfect
means as a kind of a a a power an
instrument it's increase in power that's
that can be then used indifferently so
it's it's defined in neut as neutral
yeah in itself and then it can be used
indifferently for good or for evil as
opposed to Tech was always understood as
as doing something useful I mean so it
was always it was always a means
that's appropriate to the ends that it
seeks to yeah I would I would push I'd
push back a little bit on the idea that
it that it used to be understood as
completely useful that there's a there's
this weird tradition about for example
uh the esus right so esus is the creates
these this medicine and the way he does
it is that he takes blood from the right
side of the Gorgon so he he takes this
dead gorgon and he takes blood from the
right side and and then out of that he
creates the medicine and what is
suggested obviously by that myth is that
the blood from the left side of the
Gorgon is the poison right so you have
the Venom of the snake and then you have
the the pharmacon the pharmacon yeah and
so the question of the pharmacon I think
was already quite and if you read in the
in U my mind in
Plato's when he talks about writing
what's the name of the diog yeah the
fedra uh he has he seems to have he
seems to understand that which is what
kind of jumps on in his text but he
seems to understand the duality of of
externality The Duality of application
the problem of that yeah yeah yeah I
mean I um I the The Duality but I I it
seems to me that there's a difference
between so there's always you know one
of the the best examples too is is is um
uh uh Sophocles um I think it's the the
second chorus uh I believe um from
uh the Antony I want to say heiger made
a lot of this but this this celebration
of men's uh ability but it's a
celebration that very subtly ironically
you know with that kind of sophoclean
tragic irony you realize there's
something also awful about it um and and
and destructive and terrible but it's
it's that those things are mixed
together I mean I I think that that that
that is always there I mean from the
beginning with the with the the
um Prometheus you know in a way that the
Arts are are Divine but they're they're
stolen rather than Divine gifts in fact
I mean um there there so there's there's
always a kind of ambiguity so I I think
that that's always there but I I for me
technology it's not just that it's more
ambiguous or something I think it's it's
of a very a modern technology is of a
very different nature it's a it's it's
actually a different kind of thing well
it's it's an extreme it's an extreme
version of what tech used to be even
though it used to be you know in more
ancient times they would have been more
integrated just but people could
perceive through even their integration
the possibility of the of the dangers
but now we have something like you know
a microchip yeah that will increase your
processing power by so much yeah you
know all for a medical machine or for a
missile it doesn't matter like it it's
just this it's just increase in power
and it can be used to whatever pointed
in any direction possible yeah people
see that as a good though people see
just increas in power or they say that
it it can be good right so well that's
the problem they they once we get the
power then we'll figure out how to use
it that's and they're there's a there's
a disorder that's built in but Canen
you're you keep wanting to jump in here
I don't know if if we're cutting your oh
no well I kind of got distracted there
because that just that brings us back to
this whole notion of freedom I mean as
as as soon as like as soon as Freedom
becomes takes the place of goodness as
the ultimate TS right as soon as that
becomes our goal and becomes defined as
power to make choices right then as soon
as that's I I feel like it has to do
with like why you're doing the thing if
you're doing the thing because it's
actually ordered to a real end that's
really good right like if if you're if
you're trying to build a house like it's
actually ordered to something and so
you're going to you're going to build a
hammer that has a use in relation to
something Beyond it versus you know just
building a bigger Hammer just so you can
have it because you never know when you
might need it but there's even a
trickery like in terms of increase in
power especially now because we still
live in a kind of post-christian world
there's like a weird trickery that's
that's put up to us which is that things
the technologies that are the most
destructive will be the most destructive
they're often presented to us at first
first as beneficial so it's like Elon
Musk let's put chips in your brain and
that'll people can walk I mean think
about it like I mean are you gonna say
no to that that right how can you say no
to helping people it's a total
Bailey and it's like it's the same with
with so many of these these especially
these crazy new technology especially
the biotechs it's like it's like oh you
know all this stem cell research is
great because you know all these
diseases we can cure and it's like you
don't see that there's also some very
dark things coming down the line in
terms of of uh transhumanism and
transformations of humans into who knows
what uh well that's yeah no and I I
think that that problem is a profound
and subtle one that requires real
reflection because I you know I think we
we come to such quick judgments but the
the the the the the the supposed
neutrality you get the you get the
neutral technology and then you know
then you get get afterwards the
exhortation to use it for good ends but
you know we can't help that there's
going to be some people I mean but the
very neutrality of it is
already um a departure from reality it
it it's it ends up substituting that it
creates I mean this is why I you know I
use the the language of the Diabolical
there it creates a kind of a substitute
for an engagement with reality that then
can try to justify Itself by pointing to
all of these discreet good uses but that
but in a way that's there's there's
something really deceptive about the the
whole thing and so you can under then
you look at the if you look at the at
the menite communities or the Amish and
you you look at how they do it and it's
interesting because people always think
that the Amish or these communities that
they're against technology but they're
not actually they have they always all
they do is they take every time they
someone they're presented with
technology they ask themselves what
effect will it have on our community and
then they integrate it or they don't
depending on what effect it'll have on
their Community yeah that's an
interesting approach you know obviously
on the one hand it makes them constantly
in danger of Vanishing but on the other
hand it might make them more resilient
than us in the long term when we're all
when we're all gone the Amish will still
be there no it is it is you know in fact
my wife and I just took our kids to a a
a menonite community a couple weeks ago
uh to himn sing that they did talk about
yeah these four four voice
I grew up there that that was my
upbringing oh is that right it was but
but yeah I mean that's that was the
Lites too I mean they get sort of a bad
rap and people misunderstand they
weren't they weren't against technology
either they just said that technology is
good in so far as it helps humanity and
it's bad when it stops doing that that
seems to me an eminently reasonable now
one can debate about where that line is
but it's a reasonable judgment um yeah
and it seems to me yeah there's there's
there's uh we need to recall it I mean
um yeah but it's too late now because
and this the AI question is the one that
is exposing all of this radically which
is that you they you know the this
famous uh poll that they put across the
people that are developing Ai and a
large chunk of them believe that there's
a chance that it will destroy Humanity
it's like well what that it'll destroy
all just destroy Humanity completely and
the question is how is it that they're
still doing it like what's going how do
you go to work in the morning there but
there because they think that it's
inevitable yeah and so if we don't if
they don't if I don't don't do it
somebody else is going to right and and
right well and this like this brings up
the question to me always is like it's
probably once a month that I sit and
really think honestly about ditching a
smartphone and going back to a flip
phone and ultimately I haven't done that
because there's it would basically it
would disrupt my life enough that I
won't do it but I mean when it comes to
personal application like I don't know
what what to make of this sort of
question like where do we stop like if I
don't if I don't participate with
AI am I just jumping off the boat you
first first of all have you tried Chad
gbt I've minimally amazing like it's
like you have your own research
assistant like full-time research
assistant that's what I had it I had to
analyze all all the videos on my YouTube
channel and I asked it you know what how
what would you talk about you know what
would you say Ken Ken Lowry's doing with
climbing Mount Sophia and what it gave
me back was significantly more thorough
and profound I think than I mean what I
could have what I could have put
together in you know half an hour of
typing I I have to say somebody sent me
a a a a chat GPT little essay on one of
my books just to see what I would would
think of it you know and I was
astonished first of all that that it was
as sophisticated but I but I have to say
I I quite honestly had the experience
that I often have reading some of my
grad school uh grad student papers where
you you see that they're saying things
that they that they heard you say in
class and they can put them together in
interesting ways but that they never
really got the point no that's why
they're your research assistant that's
why is not don't want it to write for
you but you can use as a research
assistant it's a it's quite astounding
but I like I I can see it like I'm not
you know my it's weird because the first
time I used chg PT it lied to me the
first time oh really you don't know that
right I mean it totally lied to me and
then about what like what
happened it was oh so I I would my my
son had been using it and he said you
got to try this I'm like and I was being
just like a grumpy old man so like like
fine whatever I'll try it and so I just
one evening I I logged into to the chat
GPT and I and I asked him if he knew
about about St Christopher because
that's obviously what I was gonna ask
him about and if if he knew that St
Christopher was a doghe headed man and
first he was like no he's a giant and
kind of argued with Chad GPT for a while
finally he admitted that St that St
Christopher is sometimes a dark-headed
man but then I asked him oh I said has
anybody ever written a a graphic novel
about St Christopher and he said yes and
I'm like really interesting and then he
gave me the name of two authors and the
name of a book that doesn't exist wow
and so then I said that book doesn't
exist and he says yes it does and I said
what's the ISBN he gives me an ISBN that
doesn't exist I said I said where can I
find he said you can find it on Amazon
you can find it on this or that I'm like
can you give me a link he gives me a
link that doesn't exist wow it was very
weird wow yeah very strange anyways yeah
well I I mean the thing is I yeah the
the the um I don't think we can give up
on these questions I I and I and I think
that the uh that the the the challenge
that this poses I mean you know that um
Jonathan you mentioned the the sanity of
going to church and having a a genuine
experience of some of these human
realities that that we don't have
elsewhere some that that yeah I mean
this this this sounds like just sort of
uh superficial exer but you know somehow
that has to penetrate into the shape of
the world too and I and uh I mean I you
know that's I guess the big task that
yeah so I the only things we I think the
thing we can do is really just because
there's also a certain faith that true
beauty Will Survive you know and it's a
it's not a just a how can I say this
obviously there are accidents but it's
not just a a kind of blank statement of
faith it's also that people care about
beautiful things and they then when they
decide to destroy a building usually
they'll destroy the nice building last
they'll destroy the ugly buildings first
and then so there's a sense in which
Beauty has a kind of evolutionary
Advantage right in terms of of of
preservation so I and so I think that
making beautiful things and beautiful
art and beautiful music is a good it's a
good strategy in terms of this our
current situation because ultimately I
think that will survive the popcorn uh
like the the The Superficial
advertisement culture yeah
yeah at least as an artist that's been
my and also like for me it was aim high
it was like okay
well where is the place where this is
still true and the answer was it's still
Church art that's the place where it's
actually true it's where all of it comes
together where you can make beautiful
things that are integrated into people's
lives integrated into and also directed
towards God and directed towards the
highest things and so it's it was still
it seems still possible you know even I
had a good friend of mine who was a he
was more he a atheist and modern person
and and he said he said uh he
said he said you know what you're doing
is also kind of just nostalgic it's just
Nostalgia it's just pasti and Nostalgia
and and my answer was well it's not
Nostalgia for the person that buys an
icon for their their nephew that's
getting baptized I don't know what to
tell you it just isn't like if I if it
gets if if I make a a chalice for a
church and there's wine in it it's like
there's no it's not Nostalgia you can
say what you want it's a real it's a
real thing it's really happening yeah
yeah it might seem retrograde to to you
but it's a it's not Nostalgia it's a
real thing and and uh uh if it's
genuinely beautiful uh we always
experience genuine Beauty as still
alive um if it's simply a repetition of
an old form I mean people sense that too
it's not yeah when it's too when it's
too much of a I always say I actually
say that I think tradition without
Nostalgia which is that yeah interesting
learn the language from the inside and
then create things you can copy at the
beginning obviously you have to start by
copying uh but once you've mastered the
the the language you have to be careful
not to just make pasti images yeah K 's
idea of tradition is recollection
forward that's a great yeah that's a
great way of saying it recollection
forward day yeah yeah well this may be a
good a good place to to bring it bring
it to a close but um any final thoughts
or anything you wanted to say before we
close
here for either of you I'd say thanks
think yeah and it would be great to have
another
conversation yeah so hopefully um I John
John wanted to come to this one but he
wasn't available so hopefully we can get
another one on the books um that would
be wonderful yeah I mean I still need to
have my conversation with John REI about
AI because he made he made a half
prophetic half scary half who knows like
that video he made on AI was was
profoundly surprising and disturbing and
so I haven't I've been Gathering up my
just my thoughts to talk to him about it
uh I would love to be in on that
conversation if you do it so maybe so
yeah it's it's definitely it's
definitely something that he's thought a
lot about and that is worth engaging
with him about it because he's
definitely he's not a he's coming at it
with you know years and years of of
thinking about these questions but it
doesn't definitely doesn't come to the
same conclusions I do but it's worth
like I think it' be worth exploring
it